[Music]
most people hosting a travel show want
to do it they love doing it they have a
sense of adventure that's not me
okay this is crazy oh god I think I'm
feeling a heart attack coming on I think
they got the wrong guy for the job
I said to my agent I'm definitely not
the person for the show this is one
Cowboy that will never have his own
movie whoa
this has taken me all over the world
places I probably would never have
gotten to if it hadn't end for the show
the Maldives that was the longest trip
of all the places to get to a lot of
flying traveling again not one of my
favorite things
whoa sweaty pops we wanted Eugene to
experience Paradise to see how he felt
when he was here it's not as easy as
sitting on the couch with a bowl of
popcorn I promise you you'll see a lot
of wildlife tonight
going into a jungle at night in Costa
Rica you know looking for poisonous
snakes let's say you get bit about an
hour you're gonna have an hour to get to
the hospital that's right and the
hospital is half far 45 minutes away uh
why are we still here yeah I'm still
kind of wondering why I'm doing it I was
in Lapland the Arctic Circle ice
floating I could not be more out of my
comfort zone than I am right this second
reindeer meat okay here we go it's in
dog sleds well it's been nice knowing
you oh my god South Africa wow I never
really had any desire to go on a safari
or whatever I thought I had seen it all
at the zoo
oh my I have to say it's been a bit of
an eye-opener for me
I think some things I would never have
done that's a long
I'm set in a show that looks gorgeous
the cinematography that's going into
making the series is incredibly
important we've got drone teams in the
air we've got a great Director of
Photography with his camera team and we
want to transport the viewer to these
completely amazing locations there's a
lot of talent a lot of great work
putting the show together making it look
as good as it does in spite of the fact
I'm the guy in the middle of it no
matter what country I'm in I always know
that there's going to be some laughs and
some good times it's really about the
people and and the culture you're kind
of looking at what everybody's doing and
finding out how they're doing it wow and
what the background is and what their
history is part of our culture and our
language will always be with you thank
you this is amazing this is this is
really special so at my age right now
oh God I think it's something I needed
to be forced to do I can't believe I did
it
and I've even surprised myself
my shoe Huskies
I'm the luckiest guy in the world I'm
glad it happened and I never thought I
would say that